welcome back everybody this is the hero
daily uh when it comes to leaks you know
that a lot of them aren't real but this
person is someone that you could
definitely trust because they have
proven themselves in the past and that
is my time to shine hello in the
community of people who are interested
in leaks and whatnot you know that this
is a trusted source and let me tell you
that today i am going to be giving you
the comprehensive list of everything
they have posted so far for dr strange
and the multiverse of madness uh these
are no particular orders some are
definitely things you have heard but
this is again just the comprehensive
list that you guys can come back to and
look at when the movie comes out and
compare it to what they have posted
let's get started
wonder will fight charles xavier who is
leading the multiversal illuminati
against her the events of the movie will
take place two years after one division
where we will see strange base a
difficult choice between ending juana's
life to save the universe or abiding by
his hippocratic oath and dooming all of
reality the previous shots are probably
legit tom cruise was in talks at one
point to appear as tony during wanda's
battle with xavier she's wearing black
pants and a white shirt covered in blood
which is why i think the pre-viz is
legit the blood is from the members of
the illuminati xavier has a hover chair
and a small but significant role they
could easily hide it in the marketing
wand is not wearing the scarlet witch
outfit because this isn't actually our
wanda not her body anyway juana from the
illuminati universe looks just like our
wanda face wise xavier fights wanda
inside her mind evan peters is not in
the movie captain carter won't die wanda
is the main villain schuma only has a
small role as a demon wanda summons to
bring chavez to her the darkhold is the
reason it's corrupting wanda's mind with
the idea of doing whatever it takes to
get her kids back it makes her think
they need help and are in danger
somewhere in the multiverse wanda is
trying to reach them but can only use
astral projection to travel the
multiverse and she needs to make it so
her whole body could go through to get
her kids the solution is chavez who can
create portals wanda uses a dark hole to
summon demons to bring chavez to her but
the demons destroy everything in their
way including chavez's reality davis
gets to the mcu and seeks help and gets
to strange who's attending palmer's
wedding at the time and then schumac
gets there and is attacking new york
strange beats schuma and talks to chavez
after that strange goes to wanda and
they have a fight strange tries to bring
her back to her senses but there's no
use wanna get to the comataj and blow
the place up looking for javas strange
and chav is a run into other realities
escaping wanda they go through a lot of
crazy places till they get to a mordo
variant who's the master of the mystic
arts of this universe they go through a
lot of crazy places till they get to a
mortal variant who's the master of the
mystic arts in his universe he tricks
him and brings them to the illuminati a
police keeping force of the multiverse
led by charles xavier they put strange
and chavez in prison to get to them
wanda takes over the body of his
universe's wanda who's just a normal
housewife with her kids she uses her
body to kill some of the illuminati and
get chavez out but before she can do
that xavier enters her mind and tries to
freak her mind from mcu wanda he's also
trying to reach mcuanda and help her
come to her senses when wanda finally
gets to her kids she realizes they were
never in any danger and were living
happily with the other wanda in that
universe on a farm the kids want their
real mother back and fear this wanda
this breaks wanda and she disappears but
not before she but not before she does
the same thing she did in one division
but this time the whole multiverse
strange and travis get back to the mcu
but the multiverse is more broken than
ever i'm guessing what wanda did will
get her kids to the mcu and they'll be
older her sadness and madness is the
cause of the wave slash blast of energy
similar to wandavision not sure if the
multiverse gets hexed but something
happens to it and it's not good it's a
wanda and strange movie mcu mordo is
only seen for five minutes trying to
hunt wanda before she kills him mcu
palmer only has a small role while
illuminati palmer is the main one we see
loki was not in the version i heard but
reshoots might have changed it magic is
not in the movie monica is a variant
rintra is on strange and wong's team to
help fight wanda mordo from the
illuminati verse is also a bad guy who
betrays the illuminati for wanda he will
stick around after the movie there are
six members of the illuminati mcu will
be named earth 616. strange gets a comic
accurate suit at one point darkhold
castle exists ending gives house of m
vibes xavier will be a variant from the
x-men films ultron drones arrest
estranged strange asking one to help him
is followed by him realizing that she's
the one sending demons from the
multiverse into the mcu and they fight
supreme strange isn't the villain and
his role isn't even that big wanda and
mordo varian are the main villains mr
fantastic is one of the illuminati
members they added more members after
reshoots there are illuminati members
and there are helpers homer variant some
other x-men and ultron drones controlled
by stark variant are helpers wanda is
full villainous and ends up winning i'm
not sure but she might do a reverse no
more mutants and bring them instead of
getting rid of them they had ideas from
many characters to cameo not sure how
many actually made it in black bolt was
an idea early on and not sure if he's in
the film
again this is not in any particular
order this is just a comprehensive list
of four plot leaks from my time to shine
hello so you can come back to this one
when the movie comes out compare it see
if it actually came true i would say
that it mostly does
uh this is again the trusted source
let me know in the comments what you
guys think if you are excited for this
movie what you're looking forward to
most i would really appreciate it
remember please subscribe turn on
notifications i am doing this every day
i'll see you guys tomorrow